bonjour et bienvenue sur canal tv pour
la suite de ce championnat du monde de
2016 donc sixième partie aujourd'hui
après les scènes que première partie où
les joueurs ne sont pas arrivés à se
départager on est donc ici avec sergueï
kaliakine le russe donc pièce blanche
face au tenant bien sûr le champion du
monde en titre magnus carsen norvégien
que va-t-il se passer dans cette partie
de carrière qui ne va varier où c'est
que carsen va proposer autre chose c'est
toujours l'inconnu dans une championnat
du monde
et bien c'est parti tout de suite kayak
il continue insiste avait que 4 et
qu'arsène que va-t-il faire maintenant
pas même voilà donc à ces partis tout de
suite encore la réponse symétrique du
pion du roi cavaliers froid qu'avait
laissé si cela n'est pas étonné pour
l'instant puisque c'est encore les mêmes
cours que les parties précédentes
fouilles b5 ne varie pas karekin
toujours la rue lopez toujours le schéma
du grand maître espagnol du 16e siècle
le fameux le très grand rui lopez c'est
partit ensuite part à 6 voilà car c'est
le continu fois quatre cavaliers si ce
petit rock c'est les même coin que les
parties précédentes
pas la peine de revenir dessus si ce
n'est justement commenté et bien qu'on à
répétition de la même ouverture fawcett
tour déjà vu b52 3 tout ceci est normal
de tir hoc alors à noter qu'ici dans
cette position si les blancs jouent la
grande variante ici c'est 3 pour jouer
des quatre bien les noirs peuvent jouer
le fameux gambie marshall avec des cinq
c3 pour que des 4es du noir jouent des
cinq prises prises et ensuite on va
prendre le pian e5 on peut voir à cette
variante
je vais vous montrer un petit peu à quoi
ça ressemble
c'est un bon beat dans un sacrifice de
pions voilà sacrifice de pions des cinq
ans by marchât alimenté par frank
marshall en début du 20e siècle prise
câble et prendre ensuite on prend 1,5
cela va les prendre pour prendre là on
va donner un pur avec les noirs rupture
ou 5 est ici pour ne pas perdre de temps
on peut en venir avec les bénéfices mais
les plus efficaces on a trouvé depuis
marshall puisque marcherait est proposé
khalef si je crois bien donc ici cc6
voilà on vous sait 6 pour protéger le
cavalier sans perdre de temps à revenir
à 9,6 l'idée c'est de jouer food et 6
avec le fou qui commence à jouer h
depuis la dame va venir en h4 à une très
très grosse attaque
le fonds va sortir les blancs en retard
de développement contre le pion et
dernièrement c'est le grand joueur
anglais michael adams 1 qui avait repos
populariser ce gambie la fin des années
90 et qui a donc il ya obtenu
d'excellents résultats avec ça donc sur
b5 four b3 petit rock 6 et 3 peut être
des cinq est possible et c'est peut être
que prévoir à kars l écart qu'ils jouent
h3 une petite variation qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même les blindes pas à
jouer ses trois donc en cas de conduite
peut-être que les blancs se développent
plus vite leurs cavaliers et ça serait
peut-être plus risqué de jouer des cinq
ici très certainement un peu car scène
joue au foot de set mais a noté kissy
joue pas des six ans l'un des six
lettres option sans doute ici si on dit
bon mais tant pis opale gambeat marshall
ou des 6es ont continué d un grand
classique
l'espagnol mais dans une joute bessette
dont qui laisse planer le doute ce qui
va jouer des 6 ou des cinq malin ce
qu'arsène caille qu'elle joue des trois
donc on n'empêche qu'il est ici voilà au
bout des trois exceptions très solide si
lecavalier bouge il ya toujours le pion
5 emprise des trois dans la lignée des
parties précédentes
la c1 car celle de jouer quand il
pleuvait des 6es on est à peu près dans
les schémas l'espagnol classique décide
donc je crois qu'à la simple cavale et
le four à bouger puisqu'on a joué à
trois sans doute comme carey qui n'a
joué
dans les parties précédentes où ces
trois et ensuite peut-être c'est celle
qu on a vu des parties de ce type là est
là mais regardez sait qu'arsène qui
innovent et jeu là je connaissais par
vincent rousseau 2 ça devrait se jouer
sans doute mais c'est une semi surprise
on va dire parce que c'est quand même
pas pas courant dans cette position là
ils jouent des scènes quand même voilà
c'est le gambit marshall si on veut
c'est la même idée il ya un certificat
de pion central mais revient que la
structure est pas quand même là même
puisqu'on a joué des trois avec les
blancs donc déjà prêt à sortir le fou
sur cases noires le cavalier peut se
retirer en c3 alors que cantona joue
c'est trop on peut pas bon voilà donc
c'est très intéressant de voir ce qui va
se passer et on prend des 5
bien sûr il faut renforcer tes la
meilleure façon de réfuter en gambie on
le dit souvent c'est de l'accepter
finalement il faut rentrer dedans et
puis jouer avec le pion de plus bien sûr
l'adversaire rassemble prévu la grosse
activité
mais on pourra rendre le pion peut-être
plus tard ou même gagné un final avec
une tonne plus s'ils l'attaquent fasse
pas bien sûr car les prends cavale et
prend 1,5 et là dans l'idée du grand
louis marchal on prend du cavalier et
puis on joue foulée 6 mais une fois
qu'on a joué à troyes folie si c'est
moins mordants donc en fait là car scène
propose aux coûts sans doute plus actif
et dans l'esprit de la position s'est
calé d42 super guerrier au centre
notamment ce fou maintenant c'est fini
il est mort on le sait dans l'espagnol
se fout de cases blanches
il est crucial donc finalement peut-être
sacrifice de pions a pour objectif
premier déjà d'éliminer ce four b3 ce
qui est son autre est important et
toujours donné une excellente activité
au blanc avec la paire de fou voilà on à
la paire de fou dans une position quand
même un petit peu ouverte
déblayer un peu le centre donc ses
fonctions puissant donc la carre à carre
à carre qui n'est sous le feu des noirs
c'est le cas les blancs olympiens de
plus bon c'est sûr qu'on peut pas dire
qu'il a raté son début mais en termes
d'ouverture en tout cas il s'est fait
preuve d'initiative par les noirs c'est
à dire c'est pas lui
vraiment qui a choisi la variante c'est
car c'est lui qui le premier voilà
propose de se se so millau me marchal
voilà donc il faut faut voir ça cette
optique-là l'aura noté un je le répète
un pour ceux qui n'auraient pas vu ce
les parties précédentes que et bien le
livre le fameux livre en livre de
capablanca de 1920 juste après son match
contre juste avant son match contre
large classe caire a pour la première
fois été traduit en français par pascal
collet qui qui a été interrogée sur
fréquence des banales le podcast aller
voir le podcast retombées locales et
découvrez le très grand livre de
casablanca qui justement commente pour
la première fois donc à ce moment là
donc bientôt champion du monde capable
en cas nous commente ça
la première partie de l'histoire d'un
gambie marshall puisque c'est lui même
qui s'est vu faire jouer par marshall en
phase avec les noirs le fameux non bits
et il explique très bien ce qui s'est
passé dans sa tête à ce moment là
capablanca et c'est fascinant à lire
vraiment c'est un morceau de l'histoire
du jeu d'échecs extraordinaire on se
livre de 1920 de capablanca ma carrière
ici kiel où il recommande ce n'est sur
beaucoup d'autres partis avec un style
extrêmement élégant voilà donc il faut
le rappeler parce qu'on est vraiment
dans l'espagnol dans le non bio à
challes voilà capable quand je vous
rappelle qu'on puisse choquer le monde
cubain on n'est pas loin de l'espagne à
ce moment-là ça reste une bien sûr une
un pays qui reste très lié à l'espagne
voilà donc on continue cette partie
après cette petite ce petit aparté sur
capable en quarts elle se dit marshall
cavaliers c3 pour les blancs logique
voilà on sort encore une pièce faut
sortir ces pièces et puis essayer de
profiter du campus donc rentrer en
finale avec une tour de plus mes
activités des noirs est forte alors que
fait car c'est maintenant fait cavaler
b4
les b 4 c'est intéressant on libère ici
la diagonale du fou bessette
on pousse pourquoi pas les blancs a joué
à troyes dans ce cas là quand on prendra
le cavalier et bien on sera obligé de
prendre pioncer voilà ici si on prend
qui arrivent et 3 le pion c sera obligé
de prendre et si à l'après à 3 et sinon
on est obligé de supporter un caillou
mais cathy pénible il fait pression sur
des trois sur ces 2 on s'est quand même
c'est un travail est pénible
voilà donc les noirs en optimiser au
maximum leurs pièces ainsi ils ont
vraiment bien bien placé leurs joueurs
fou et 4 bien pour car yakine très bons
coups le fou est en défense du roi on
sait jamais puisque l'on voit bien qu'il
y ait un petit peu des nuages contrôler
la caisse de seine pour une sortie feu
là les premiers 3 il a bien sûr on
reprend du pied au ras et c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas joué à trois îlots de
pions bien serré il n'y a pas de
problème ces cinq les blancs centralise
même leur carlier carioca temps ça c'est
amusant dans cette partie on a vu à leur
club les noirs avaient joué les deux cas
valises sont et 5 et d4 et maintenance
et les blancs qui le met sur 4 et 5
une réponse comme ça asymétrique c'est
très très artistique
on voit bien ici là la beauté du jeu
avec une prendre avec quelques temps de
retard les blancs répète une manoeuvre
qui a joué noire joli coup positionnelle
de car c'est maintenant regarder m6
voilà c'est bien souvent dit que ça peut
affaiblir le roi déjouer le piège certes
mais il ya plus fous justement de cases
blanches ceci dit on a aussi affaibli la
case de 6 faut faire attention parce
qu'il y aura une fourchette sur mettez
un cavalier ici bon dernier pas en tout
cas en attendant les cavaliers 5 mai sur
l'attaqué qu'elle est roi il ya tout de
suite les noirs voilà déblayent le
centre f 5 après avoir chassé un premier
cavalier
on chasse le second et qu'arsène dit à
khanaqinne et tu vas ou alors si
lecavalier vient en c3 par exemple qui
est pas bien sûr le plus actif on peut
regarder et bien les noirs pourrait ici
jouer peut-être regarder le coup
faut prendre cavaliers ici là ce fou
pour reprendre le cavalier pourquoi
parce que si on prend de la dame
il ya ces deux kits homme avec une
fourchette voilà et si on prend du plomb
mais on a cassé son roi ici donc c'est
passé patrice est pas envisageable
donc ce collège 3,5 faut jouer beaucoup
plus dynamique que voie car yakine bien
sûr ces cavaliers cinq cavaliers suisses
et voilà qu'un léger 5
c'est évidemment un excellent coup
puisque on vise la classe de 6 avec une
fourchette dam tour vous allez voir
c'est pas très grave car c'est là tout
vu ils déblayent encore une fois le
l'échiquier en rdc très joli fond
pranger 5 très simplement et
environnement il quand même hein c'est
gonflé quand même ils donnent grand la
paire de fou mais il va vous allez voir
simplifier tout ça après calais projet
cinq stations yann fourchette ici mais
c'est pas grave
regardez ce qui fait car celle à 6 quand
même très étonnant une fourchette et ils
me regardent et clavier si ce calcul de
carcelle et tout ça a été forcée depuis
m6 tout était français quasiment on l'a
vu même tout s'est efforcé tout court
regardez md5
oui ou intermédiaire tu m'attaques de
pièces mais celle là
en venant des simples j'attaque g2 je me
la smat donc là le seul coup et saufs à
louis sur le secoue mais aussi il est
élégant en même temps f3 f3 regarder je
restreins évidemment la puissance des
pièces noires sur case blanche
c'est un très beau ici schéma de défense
d'autant que je garde le foot cases
noires donc les canards sont tenus par
le fou donc c'est une façon élégante la
de lutter contre des pièces très actif
sur une couleur de quasi siens voilà
tous ses pions en contre contrôle à la
puissance du fou du foot 17
mais là maintenant c'est l'heure on a
enlevé une pièce de l'attak on enlève la
deuxième tour et fait 8 mois là il s'est
rien passé
il n'y a pas eu voyez qu'il n'y a pas eu
de
il ya peu une fourchette
alors là ceci dit on pourrait se poser
la question mais qu'est ce qui se passe
sur calais c'est cette qui fait une
triple fourchette on peut le regarder ça
c'est pas un très bon coup puisque
simplement les noirs jouer tout reproche
très certainement en premier
dame prend force et maîtres de langue
tout simplement on peut jouer dam des
quatre échecs au rang et si les blancs
pour pas perdre de temps ici jouent le
coup qui semble évident fouet 3 d'accord
mais c'est pas bon jouer long pour jouer
encore simplement cavaliers de cinq
accords et si on prend la torah 8 au
regard des fourchettes ça y est enfin il
ya la fourchette qui traînait pitt alors
on attaque dam tour on va prendre la
tour le foot emprise lecavalier est en
prison récupère le matériel avec une
structure meilleur pour les noirs
puisque les pions en berne et les pions
noirs souvent beaucoup plus blot boclé
que les pions blancs
donc c'est pas bon du tout alors servir
bon faut faire attention à ça faut pas
sauter sur une seconde info be calculé
tout reprend dans prend et il ya le curé
qui prend en c2 on peut même jouer échec
un terme hier on vient de le voir etc on
a tout le temps de placer la fourchette
donc ici tours 5
voilà 3 5 carats qui l'enjoint scuba
évite un éventuel échec
il peut menacer devenir ans et c'est
toujours puisque à priori tout reprendre
tour échec et le fou attaquerez c7
voyez donc il faut calculer ce genre de
coups toujours il faut que les nord
fasse attention ici est-ce qu'ils vont
jouer donc ici un coup intéressant des
six et ça c'est un beau coup l'idée
d'anne decis si les blancs jouent cave
et laissé 7
ça marche pas alors l'idée de calais
c'est cette seller si la dame prend le
cavalier pourpre en échec tout reprend
et la dame est perdu par le fou mais non
la halle nord peuvent prendre la tour
voyez qu'ils n'ont pas peur de la
découverte comme d'amd s'ils se mettent
en découverte du fou mais c'est pas très
grave
on peut réguler ans a reculé à tour
aussi il n'est sûr ici aussi on pour
jouer autour d'eux parce que maintenant
puisque le fou est protégé par le
cavalier dame devrait jouer et on
pourrait me lasser qu'à laisser ces
temps pour regarder ce qui se passe ici
surtout re2 qui sont même beaucoup tout
à fait c'est parce que je jouais
khanaqinne on va voir ça après tours 2
ça sent le monde puisque je vais me
lancer qu'à laisser cette mais c'est pas
une vraie vraie menace il suffit que les
noirs jouent dame 17 simplement est sûr
que l'essai 7 qui semble faire une
fourchette patio pareil un échange
d'intermédiaires je prends d'abord en
deux temps prend et maintenant il suffit
que je sorte ma tour par exemple passer
8 et les blancs des problèmes nouvelle
cavalli est obligé de revenir aussi si
on peut le clou et il faut faire
attention il ya moyen de s'en sortir
mais c'est tendu
voilà s'il n'y a rien de simple donc on
va pas on va pas vers les sept variantes
puisque c'est pas du tout ce qu'a fait
karim donc il fait ici c3 c3 dont qui
rend le pion ici on aurait bien qu'ils
rendent le pion en d3 nous éleveurs car
ça ne va jouer encore plus fun si les
noirs avaient joué cavale et prendre des
trois ils auraient pu eux mêmes prendre
ces cinq ans on peut regarder c'est
compliqué sûr qu'elle allait prendre des
3 et blanc aurait pu faire tout reprend
ses 5
oui parce que si on prend le cas vahid à
tour bien sûr caprices de dame mais les
blogs pour reprendre quand même enfin
prendre 17 ans s est fait est là et noir
simplement pour reprendre le cavalier e
6 lip6 après d'âpres en d3 la structure
des pions blanche n'est pas mauvaise ici
voilà j'ai trois pions contre 2 3 pions
contre trois avec une bonne structure de
pions j'ai un bon piont de plus un
entrefilet un bon point de plus il
faudrait que noirs ici donc rendre
récupère ici en b3 et puis on est dans
ce cas là simplement dame 17 et des
blancs les noirs les blancs dont on lui
nie cette île les blancs initiative il
attaque le fou attention la dame
commence à visée g7
on peut envisager faut 5 avec une messe
de maths on peut jouer autour c'est 7
il faut absolument revenir en réponse
est dans cette variante est ici
simplement d'un prend
prends tours 3-1 et j'ai toujours en
plus vous voyez que c'est pas bon donc
sur ces trois ils craquent pas un quart
scène il fait pas n'importe quoi bien
entendu ce qu'il avait prévu il le joue
3,6 tout simple au lieu de sauver ce
cavalier ou de le bouger
vu que l'autre était en prison le prend
puisque carla qui n'a fait que
contre-attaqué le camélia pour preuve
6dans prend 1,6 et après qui on prend
ces 4 puis on prend ces 4 bilan des
courses pour carcelle balle assez
positif et noir sont mieux même si bien
sûr ça suffira certainement pas puisque
en fait on a ici au regard d une
structure depuis complètement éclaté on
a récupéré le pion de de moins pour les
noirs on a par contre nous les noirs ici
on a un gros une grosse structure de
publier ici là aussi nos pions
comprendre proprement de place et donc
l'avantagé noirs en terme de structure
par contre il ya les fous et femmes un
fou de couleurs opposées ce qui est un
facteur à l'une annulant en finale donc
à des changes des dames et et de tour
encore plus si les pièces pour ses
chants chassera très facilement
annulables mais ce qu'il ya aussi c'est
la possibilité d'attaquer avec les fous
de couleurs opposées
voilà ça peut être aussi infections en
attaque donc il faut quand même faire
attention il reste encore un peu de jeu
donc les blancs doivent être précis avec
quand même gros chance deux nuls mais
ils sont moins bien là d'ailleurs voilà
des gars n a réussi avec un tour de
magie
grosse activité des pièces avec un
gambit marche elle retardées on peut
dire une sport une sorte de damier
marche elle retardait la même idée à
obtenir une grosse initiative dans l'est
dans l'esprit de ce lundi contre le pion
et ça a payé
voilà tour c'est un tocsin 8 échanges
voilà car ce n 'est qu' on peut pas
vraiment mener des attaques
il accepte les simplifications échange
de tours pour prend pas me prendre
ça va être dur parce qu'on voit pas
comment les noirs peuvent attaquer ça
c'est très solide 6 affaibli ce même
pour attaquer bien c'est les blancs qui
seront très dangereux sur quade noir
vous voyez l équilibre de la terreur
avec les cases comme ça de foot que le
reposer et reste des pièces lourdes mais
les dames mais c'est pour faire monter
une attaque c'est quand même peu chaud
mais bon j'ai encore des possibilités
donc ça joue encore un peu comme un
homme 17 h 2a scène voilà ça y est
attention enfin fort que les blancs
réagissent mise en mouvement a envoyé de
la majorité 3 contre 2 ici on pousse on
pousse on pousse on va pouvoir faire des
pions passé attention l'adami civis bb
bb b 4 ici donc il faut il faut protéger
c'est pas facile d'ailleurs pour vous
pouvez noir même d'ailleurs si les
blancs me l'empêcher totalement
infondées de aussi possible attention
aussi les pions des trois reprises donc
si hassen j'ai protégé des trois étangs
prise faut faire quelque chose voilà
dans le iii attentive bons coups le 3 je
peux ensuite pénétré en b 6 voire en c5
il faut faire attention des cinq allées
noires centralise leur fout on met un
fou qui peut revenir en défense aussi
vers le roi et puis on attaque b3 voilà
très bien placé au centre toujours les
pièces si on peut les mettre au centre
n'oubliez pas mettre une pièce au centre
s'est lui donné souvent le maximum de
potentiel de jeu dans b6 attaque la base
ici à 5
et puis on va donner en des huîtres un
échec est possible aussi on peut aussi
revenir en d4 tension d'être comprise
elle est noire choisir quand même
d'échanger carsen simplifie cherche pas
ici c'est qu'on peut pas faire grand
chose donc dans prend à cinq ils
n'insistent pas trop non plus il prend
des trois aussi voilà d'en prendre b4
maintenant les blancs n'ont plus de
désavantages structurels voyez c'est
très difficile d'envisager quoi que ce
soit puisque les blancs auraient pu
replacer leur fou ce classement a
réattaqué le roi noir on peut rien faire
sans risquer des gros soucis aux six les
blancs et les noirs conviennent à ce
moment-là de signer la paix des braves
très belles parties de surtout de carsen
j'ai envie de dire parce que ankara qui
n'a pas démérité bien sûr il avoue une
belle partie mais il s'est fait
surprendre quand même par les noirs dans
l'ouverture c'est pas lui qui a varié
voilà il a insisté un petit peu à la
main avec la méthode russe la méthode
des champions du monde russes qui ont
tous cependant
leur championnat du monde essayait de
pousser l'adversaire sur une seule
variante de le essayer de le restreindre
sur une variante et on voit bien qu'à
contrario de ce que pourrait essayer de
faire de penser les blancs ici ce sont
les noirs qui ont pris l'initiative ce
sont les noirs qui ont varié qui n'ont
pas voulu répéter les variantes
antérieures mais qui ont essayé de poser
des problèmes aux blancs en changeant de
variantes et car la guinée risque se
retrouve un peu le bec dans l'eau à la
fin du match parce que si si car c'est
le surprend à chaque fois qu'il n'est
pas capable de le mettre en difficulté
comme jusqu'à présent on voit bien que
car c'est nuit par contre est passé pas
loin de deux gars avec un avantage net
dans de finale tendue précédemment il
mène aux points car scène mais il ya
toujours pas de vraie pouvait marquer
donc toujours match nul alors le match
resté indécis passionnant à suivre on le
voit il ya une vraie diva sur l'espagnol
ça faisait longtemps
ça faisait depuis kasparov et karpov
qu'on n'avait pas eu ça un vrai grand
débat théorique sur la sur l'espagnol
sur la variante de berlin qui s'est
immiscé un petit peu dans cette théorie
aussi un voix voilà donc c'est assez
passionnant duo théorique de belles
finales de beaux schémas tactiques
c'est vraiment un super championnat du
monde interne en terme de qualité de jeu
voilà merci de m'avoir suivi se déroule
altéré je vous donne rendez-vous donc
pour la prochaine partie la 7e là où
c'est ça la septième partie donc bientôt
et donc à la prochaine fois au revoir